as nintendo continues to reveal these
little mini trailers to hype up age of
calamity
things are getting more and more
interesting to say the least
as of writing this script there are
currently two of these short trailers
out there called the untold chronicles
of 100 years past parts 1
and 2. both trailers while only about 40
seconds long have revealed some pretty
important details regarding characters
that will make appearances in the game
surprisingly they're mostly characters
we already knew about in the original
game that takes place 100 years after
this one
in just over a month when the game
releases we're going to see youthful
versions of pura and robbie and even the
dreadful master koga himself
along with some completely new
characters to add to the roster
there's this big boy clad in yiga armor
that apparently spars off against link
and zelda at some point in the game and
also another mysterious hooded figure
that's most likely the fortune teller
that hyrulegamer and celtic have been
talking about over on their channels and
doing an awesome job too by the way if
either of you are watching but of
all of these big character reveals one
that people have been a little
dismissive about
is the aforementioned big boy of the
yeaga clan
this large but surprisingly spry
individual
immediately caught my attention because
of his unique appearance
with stuff like the mcdonald's m signs
sticking out of his head in his apparent
proximity and importance to master koga
himself
in fact he intrigued me so much that i
had to go and make this theory video
about it and we will get right into it
but real quick i wanted to remind you to
double check to make sure you're
subscribed to the channel to stick
around for all the goodness to come
and be sure to drop a like if you enjoy
the video so it can spread around on
youtube
and now let's talk about the big boy the
first and most
important details i want to point out
about big boy would be
big boy's appearance as i alluded to
just a second ago
besides his wobbly mcdonald's logo which
i'm pretty sure is
actually his hair sticking out of the
top of his hood kind of like all the
other yiga clan members
there are several key takeaways from his
outfit that we can derive information
from
first up being his mask notice anything
different about it well it has these
windy
horn-like segments sticking out of the
sides of the mask a feature only present
on one other mask yep master koga's
since these two are the only individuals
whose masks feature horns
by default that would indicate not only
some relation between them two but
some degree of importance elevated above
the other members of the yiga but we'll
get further into that later on
next up in similar fashion is his collar
if you look around none of the other
yiga members
scouts or blademasters have callers like
big boys
not only does it look super shanazi but
again the only other person to feature
grandeur collars around the neck of
their tight suits
would be master koga and yet another
similarity to koga's outfit would be big
boy's earrings
which are rather banana shaped just like
koga but also just like the other blade
masters
however the other blade masters do not
wear eye plates
no not plates around their eyes but the
plates of shoulder armor that big boy is
wearing that are designed to look
like eyes which is kind of a big
symbolic thing with the chica and yiga
clans
that is again something only seen on
master koga are you picking up on a
pattern yet
good because i am too now let's talk
about the other features we were able to
pick up on in this rather short
trailer the coolest thing about big boy
to me is the fact that he actually
one-ups his fellow blademasters by
duo-wielding two of these super
cool-looking swords that have unique
hilts never before seen in breath of the
wild meaning these weapons are unique to
this individual once again
serving to elevate his importance he's
also shown to not only be
as i've mentioned several times a big
boy but also
rather nimble and quick on his feet with
reflexes to boot
able to execute a lethal backward slice
while running away and immediately
perform a back handspring into backflip
just before vanishing in signature yiga
assassin's style
furthermore it seems clear to me that
this event we're able to catch a glimpse
of is one of the assassination attempts
made on princess zelda's life
alluded to in the book creating a
champion that link was fortunately able
to stop once again it looks like big boy
is leading the attempt
meaning he's a member of great
significance but between this event and
his appearance behind master koga
on what appears to be a planning table
this is all we get to see of big boy
don't worry though i've got a few ideas
as to who big boy
actually could be or what he could
represent in the story going forward
you might want to buckle your seat belts
because this may blow your mind
possibility number one big boy
is none other than master koga
in the past i know it sounds crazy since
we see
koga right there in the trailer and they
specifically showed him
with big boy on the screen at the same
time to differentiate the two characters
but hear me out real quick
if you think about it the resounding
theme of these mini trailers so far has
been to show what characters looked like
a hundred years ago right
but we're just supposed to believe that
even though robbie was younger and
taller impa was younger and taller pura
was younger and taller
koga had the exact same short and pudgy
build
why wouldn't koga be younger and taller
and fitter as well
and i mean why else would big boy have
the extremely and
specifically similar armor features when
nobody else in the clan does
think about it it makes perfect sense to
conclude that this is a younger master
koga wearing the same armor and the
older hymn just shrunk over the hundred
years to come
like we've already seen happen to pura
robbie and impa
the only thing that needs to be
explained is obviously the appearance of
current master koga 100 years in the
past
but what if and i don't have much proof
for this but
what if somehow after pushing koga down
the yiga hole
he was actually sent back in time
somehow like i said i don't have much
proof for it but it would explain his
words at the beginning of the trailer as
well
look what you did
[Music]
well i don't mind
look what you did he says while standing
over the yiga pit
but we have no documentation of link or
anyone else doing anything bad to koga
until link defeats him
at that pit 100 years later so if koga
somehow was sent back in time to his
previous self
his words would actually make sense and
when he says
i don't mind that actually means he's
now going to be running around
in the past working with young koga and
the fortune teller with all the
knowledge of a hundred years
ready to wreck all sorts of havoc in the
land of hyrule this opens up the
possibilities for a whole bunch of
different
story twists and turns that i could
honestly talk about for a while longer
but i'll stop it there for now
the young koga theory is definitely my
favorite regarding big boy so far
second he could be related to koga
perhaps
as a son or a brother kind of like yiga
royalty a couple points towards this
theory would be that he is of course
wearing koga gear and the title of
master koga is revealed to be just
a title in creating a champion and the
yiga have also been said to revere their
master even more than they do calamity
ganon
whom they worship meaning they most
likely operate on some sort of royal
family setup to pass on the title of
master koga
if this was the master koga of a hundred
years ago perhaps it's actually the
father to our current master koga and
big boy
is current master koga but when he grows
up he turns out just like dear old dad
and then we push him down a pit
definitely possible lastly he could just
be a formidable member of the yiga clan
that due to his show of skills and
tenure amongst the other members has
been promoted to some sort of second in
command role aiding master koga
meaning the master koga shown in the
trailer is the same as our current one
which is entirely possible since he
looks the exact same
with the exact same personality and like
every important shika character is over
a hundred years old or
ten thousand years old and the yiga used
to be shiga and they have their
technology
you see where i'm going with that big
boy could just be a yiga super commander
and while this theory feels like the
most plausible one
it's definitely not the most fun to
think about but what do you think did i
touch on who big boy is in this video or
is he actually somebody else entirely
and does anybody actually know what's
with all the bananas
let me know in the comments below hey
guys thank you so much for watching it
feels really good to get back into
theories after such a long break
i want to thank those who subscribed for
sticking around and those who liked the
video for helping it spread to other
zelda fans like you and me
huge thanks as always to my amazing
supporters who make
my day every day by supporting the
channel in one of the most direct ways
possible
if you're interested in helping the next
video come to life
and reaping some pretty cool benefits
along the way check out that join button
located below
or follow the links in the description
to find out how also down there are my
social media direct links so follow
those links to follow me
on twitter that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
fantastic
rest of your day this is massington
abandon signing out
[Music]
you